it's time for our legal East segment of
the week I'm rocky CEA's Chris Berg
welcome back to Channel eight what's new
with your firms since the coronavirus
lockdown has happened and how is it
affecting law firms like yours
well the Patriot law firm is still
moving forward we're still accepting new
clients we represent folks in Nevada
Arizona and California recently we've
seen an uptick in cases involving folks
getting injured at businesses
slip-and-falls tripping falls at the
businesses that makes sense there are
more people at the grocery stores and
one-stop shopping locations but how do
you determine if there is a case or if
there is not a case all of these stores
have a duty to maintain their premises
in a reasonably safe manner for their
patrons but what does reasonably safe
mean in these crazy times well they have
a duty to keep their stores clean the
floor is clean they have a lot of folks
coming and we've all seen the lines
outside of these stores early in the
morning till very late at night with
more customers means there's going to be
more problems there's going to be more
spills if an employee makes a spill lots
of little things they can do but these
stores are well trained they know what
to do they should be taking care of
these messes but them unfortunately
sometimes they don't so if one of our
viewers falls in a store or business
what should they do well most
importantly need to make sure that
they're okay
take a self-assessment right there call
someone for help take pictures of that
spill of the liquid whatever it is that
caused you to fall whatever it is that
caused you to hurt yourself fill out a
written report at the store lastly if
you're hurt pretty seriously then call
9-1-1 Kris I heard your firm donates
money to a local charity in town for
every case you settle is that actually
true we donate money to the paralyzed
veterans of Nevada
every time we settle the case we do need
some money to those folks we're also
offering right now reduced attorneys
fees for all first responders and we
also do reductions in our fees for
military reserve and veterans so please
we'd love to help the community we need
to give back give Christopher Burke a
call at the patriot law firm at seven oh
two six two zero two zero two zero fight
for the little guy calm